going to be in ukraine where russia
unleashed an intense missile attack on
kiev during a visit by the u.n secretary
general antonio guterres had just been
to moscow where he met with russian
officials we also have breaking news
overnight there are reports this morning
of an american killed while fighting in
ukraine chris livesay is in ukraine once
again for us chris good morning this is
a 22 year old american according to
reports
that's right tony it is a 22 year old
known as willy joseph cancel he'd be the
first known american killed in action
here he's reported to have come here in
march and joined a brigade of
international soldiers fighting
alongside ukrainian forces he leaves
behind a wife and a seven month old baby
this says russia rained down rocket
attacks across the country but none more
brazen than right here in the capitol
keeve under fire with russian missiles
slamming into this apartment building
just across the street from a missile
defense factory it's the most severe
attack on the capital since russian
forces retreated weeks ago but a
reminder that the threat of russian
missiles never disappears
stunning timing and proximity as the
head of the united nations met with the
president and witnessed the russian
devastation with his very own eyes there
is no way a war can be acceptable in the
21st century look at that
antonio guterres visited where these
bodies once lay in bucha
now laid to rest
ludmila says farewell to her husband
valeri
just one of those massacred by these men
ukraine says releasing photos for the
first time of the suspected butchers of
bucha
in marieuple hundreds of soldiers and
civilians many of them wounded continue
to resist bombardment inside this steel
mill the last gasp of life in a city
reduced to blood and ash
this video is said to show russian
forces ordering soldiers not to fire as
they deliver aid but to whom we don't
see
in two months of ruthless siege warfare
these last remaining civilians have
watched their friends and family succumb
to shelling and starvation somehow these
people have survived but for how much
longer no one can say
and the american support for ukraine
continues to pour in from washington the
house gave final approval to a bill
expanding biden's authority to arm
ukraine with what it needs to fight off
russia the white house has also asked
congress for an additional 33 billion
dollars to go towards security economic
and humanitarian aid for ukraine tony
a lot of money chris livesay in ukraine
for us chris thank you very much